in liverpool big problem
massive problem humongous problem i got
a job going on in liverpool and my
builders
left my builders walked out of sight
they're going bankrupt
i haven't finished i got tight deadlines
i'm very unhappy
[Music]
do you not go to liverpool or north
world unless i say so
yeah i've got about two weeks i need to
get this
he was invoicing me for stuff i was
paying and then he was telling his work
man
oh sami was not paid he had and wasn't
paying his voice
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
now i've finally recovered
from the horrible situation with a
builder
that walked off site literally closed
down his company
and left me in the absolute poo and i
did a video on this where you may have
seen a little bit of my reaction and the
whole drama going off
however this actually did happen back in
may
and the site was then quickly finished
um there's now tenants in the property
everything's all good
but when i put the video out there's
quite a lot of people asking me in the
comment section
what are the lessons here what actually
happened how can we stop this kind of
thing happening to us
as property investors and developers and
one of the most annoying
people group to deal with when you're a
property investor is
probably not estate agents it's probably
not even valuers it probably is
builders so there are good builders
there's good and bad
in every industry but in this video i
wanted to talk you through
kind of what happened how my builders
screwed me over and how you
can make sure or at least best prevent
that from happening to you
so if you enjoy my videos uh please do
me a massive favor
hit the like button i don't have to
share the bad i could only share the
good
but um i'm very very happy to always be
transparent about my journey
the good the bad and the ugly and this
was definitely one of the ugly moments
so if you appreciate that
subscribe to the channel turn the
notification bell on
so when do this all start we found a
property
and this was not actually my property
it's for an investor and
it's quite a high profile investor and
he's a good friend of mine and
it was it's important that this deal
went smoothly
and as part of the service the investor
took on board a project management fee
from uh one of our companies better
sourced limited which is is head up by
alistair
and the property was a very small refurb
okay it needed about thirty thousand
pounds spending on it ensuites in the
bedrooms completely re-gutting but it's
a small house
i don't normally get involved in these
types of little small refurbs that are
going on
whether they're my properties whether
they're our investors joint ventures
i tend to have a very hands-off approach
however
especially by the way because the
building the builder in question
has been has done 15 jobs for us some
for me
i was there our investors 15 jobs so
i'm kind of thinking this is going to be
quite smooth however what happened was
about a month into the job i'm hearing
that
nothing's really happened it's not
really got started yet and things are
really slow i'm thinking what's going on
so iran got max who is works for better
source
and i said max that's our sourcing
company our project management sort of
company i said what's happening and max
is saying oh the builder's saying
because of the pandemic and coronavirus
because this is back in sort of like
you know february time now um
things are going slow and i just get so
ticked off
when people are using coronavirus and
pandemic as an excuse
which is what i thought this was so i
said to max max let me speak to the
builder direct i spoke to the builder
his name is dave
i said dave what's going on oh samuel is
all under control all's really well
i found out bloody going on contracts
yeah i know it's getting a bit a bit
hard for me as well because obviously i
told the client that we finished last
month so i'm i'm
getting a little bit stressed now i'm
just supposed to oh
yeah go anywhere
and click
[Music]
i'm like all right fine anyway i keep
getting complaints about this particular
house about this particular builder
things are going really slow
um so i thought you know what i'm going
to jump in and i'm going to
just get this finished so i rang up dave
i said dave
what's the schedule of works when's
everything going to happen
he's saying right we've ripped the house
we've ripped everything out now we've
put everything in the scape
you know we've had the first fix of
electrics the first fix of plumbing
so you know we've made a good start next
is this is this
so we've we've put together a schedule
of works which we agreed upon
he's using pandemic as an excuse oh we
can't have more than two people in the
house at once
because i know that i've been able to
get there because it's because of the
light
and i said darling now
the joke
yeah it's really not it's just not good
enough because it doesn't take that long
to plaster a plaster of house
um or fit a kit all fit a kitchen and
the kitchen's been in there now almost
two weeks um
and i'm looking like a right idiot uh
and this and um are out of stock here so
i said look let's put together a
schedule of works
from start to finish worst case bearing
in mind the pandemic i don't want any
excuses let's do it so we agree upon
when everything's going to happen
and that's all that and then what
happened is just every step of the way
there's a delay there's a problem and
the dave the builder kept saying to me
my wife is in hospital my wife is in
hospital now listen
if your wife is in hospital it's a
really sad situation but when a builder
or anyone a professional person starts
speaking like that
usually when their wife's in hospital or
their dad's just died or some issue
i'm not saying it's not true but often
it's an excuse
or they're trying to set the scene
they're trying to
set you up for a big disappointment so
i'm like look dave i'm really sorry to
hear about your wife that sucks but like
what
what's happening um and in the end
he said to me oh you know we just need a
little bit more money for this and just
a little bit more money for this
um we and we paid for all the ensuites
the bathrooms
we paid for all the plas the plasterers
and i went to the property no one's
there
i'm like dave what's happening and then
in the end i push i push a push i push i
push a push
and then dave walks off
he steals my money that i've paid him
for the materials
for the ensuites and the bathrooms
can't get hold of dave i get a message
from dave saying i'm winding my company
up
it's going insolvent i'm really sorry
i'm like oh my goodness she's terrible
so straight away i've lost money
now at the time i thought maybe dave is
not a bad person he's done lots of jobs
for us maybe it's just one big cock-up
however i went down to the property
and the workmen that were working on the
property was saying oh
dave says that you've not paid him so he
can't pay us
i start getting messages on instagram
from the plasterers and the plumbers
saying
we need payment so i had to literally
show
my bank statements and invoices i could
show everything had all been paid
to dave and dave had not just done that
to me
he'd done that to um alistair and he did
it to lots of other investors
he'd taken their money he'd taken as
much as he could
he didn't pay his workman and then he
just closed the company down
which is really really really bad so
rather than trying to name and shame
dave and say this is the overall company
and be careful because
you know i mean look his company's gone
bust now it's possible he might set up
but how many builders are there called
dave and how many bad builders are there
there's a lot of bad builders
so in this video i wanted to just share
some of the things
that you need to do to prevent
coming across bad cowboy builders now
this guide worked with us for quite a
long time
you might hear people saying you know
get a recommended builder
use a recommended get a referral and
then it's all okay
well actually no you can have a
recommended builder jeez you can even
have a builder that you've used 15 times
but
things can still go bad so what's some
of the further due diligence that you
need to do what are some of the further
checks and skills that you need to
prevent things like this
happening there's a few things i want to
say around those points
firstly when you're getting a builder
whether you've had a
used a builder before whether they're a
trusted builder before you instruct the
builder to actually start works
get a survey on the property because one
of the things that builders sometimes do
cowboy builders is they'll pretend that
things are wrong with the property that
might not be wrong
and this is dave tried this on with me
dave was saying
oh you know this needs to be done oh
there's a problem with underneath
these bricks and they create extra
things that don't need doing
so they might pretend that the electrics
need completely
rewiring when they don't when the
electrics aren't actually that bad but
if you
if you don't know anything about
electrics you can't see what's happening
how can you know
oh it's gonna cost three and a half
thousand pounds for a new rewire we need
to rewire it
okay now listen if you can't know what
you're doing you might expect okay well
i'm gonna need an
electric certificate to show what's
happened and but if you're not
not really sure that's why number one is
get a survey on the property number two
is get three quotes
on the job before you start the job and
then if one builder says it's gonna cost
20 grand
and the electrics are fine and the other
one says 22 grand
electrics are fine and then somebody
else says oh well the electrics need to
be one and this
oh and start saying things that don't
actually need to be done i think that's
the first thing
second thing is as well as getting your
survey and getting three quotes
really really really important is that
you have a
schedule of works okay you have a
contract
with the builder otherwise it's just if
you
if you're just if the builder's saying
to you it's going to cost this much but
it's just all verbal
or if the builder says oh it's going to
cost 20 grand to do this entire refurb
and you go all right great
and then he sends you an invoice or he
sends you an agreement
20 grand and then as he's going through
the job he's going
oh you'll also need new windows oh
you're also going to need a new boiler
and you're saying hold on a minute
you said it was going to cost 20 grand
for the entire refurb
and then the builder might say yeah but
that doesn't include the windows
okay that's why you need a breakdown
an itemization of everything
and how much that thing cost not just 20
grand for the refurb
what does that 20 grand consist of and
then okay well the windows are going to
cost two and a half grand
the the the the carpets does the does
the quote include carpets
and decoration because that's i've seen
i see so many people get caught out on
this
the builder quotes from 25 grand and
they assume that's for a
finished product you know carpets paint
but then the builder's like no no that's
just for the actual building works
so get an itemized breakdown with
with quotes for every thing that's
needed also a schedule of works
when things are going to get done not
just oh it's going to be done by june
next year no well the first week we're
going to do this then the second week
we're going to do this the third week
we're going to
and then what you can see then if you're
falling behind
that's what happened with me with dave
i'm like dave we agreed that
this this week was the week when we're
supposed to be doing xyz
what's happening otherwise it just you
think oh it's going to be done by june
and then the end of may comes and you go
hey it's still going to be done by june
and then suddenly it's a surprise
so you want a schedule of works you want
an itemized bill
even if you've used the builder 15 times
you need to be a little bit on their
back
you need to be asking them um for what's
whatsapp pictures
regularly go and visit the site at least
once a week
okay and and and and and sometimes you
know you might want to have a site visit
where you're going to be inspecting the
work
and sometimes you want to do spot checks
i used to just i i
when i used to pop down to the property
i'd go down at 9am
no one's here they'd be rocking up at
11am and leaving at 3pm
but if you're there you can see it and
if you can't do it get somebody to be
close by
and then lastly and so so important and
listen i lost about seven grand
to this builder because he he
he um charged me for materials and then
he didn't get the materials so i had to
buy them again
but i know people that lost 20 000
pounds and more
with this same builder because some
people were
he he he rinsed me for however much he
could have went to before he was rinsing
everybody
from every which way and then with a
view to close down the company which is
why
i just thought i have to share what
happened in this video and rather than
trying
naming shame it's more about how for you
to stop it but
don't pay large amounts of money
up front okay if if the quote's gonna
cost 25 grand
and the builder says it's gonna cost 25
grand to do this refurb but i will need
payment upfront
never ever do that you always want to
stage the payments out
so you might say look i'll give you you
know
what what what's the first week going to
consist of oh the first week is going to
be rip out
all right great and then what about the
second week oh the second week is
plastering all right cool
so i'll pay you for the skip that's
needed for the rip out
and i'll pay you for all the plaster and
everything so the boys can get all ready
i'll pay that upfront so you might work
out i'll pay
you know four thousand pounds or
whatever it might be up front
and then you've got all your materials
and you can get going and then once the
rip-out's been done
i'll pay you a thousand pounds for the
labor and then once the plastering has
been done i'll pay you 3000 pounds
and you stage it and then every time you
make a new payment
go visit the property check that it's
been done and if it's been done and if
it's satisfactory
then you make the payment but don't be
paying loads of money up front because
builders
can just close the company down and do a
runner
so i think that's the biggest advice
that i could say um
another thing is how how you do anything
is how you do everything so when you're
getting builders on board if they start
making
excuses it's a bad sign if when you're
in
when you're very first getting quotes if
you're having to chase the builder
just to give you a quote if the builder
says i'll give you a quote on friday and
then monday comes and you've not had it
and you're chasing them you can't get
hold of them
bad sign bad sign because how you do
anything is how you do everything
so those are just a few lessons i could
probably spend two days
talking about how to manage and project
managed builders another little tip is
to just have a little whatsapp group
with everybody that's involved in the
refurb um
and and then you can all communicate
communication
that's the biggest thing communication
be in regular communication with your
builder
make sure you're on the same page things
will go wrong that's okay
there might be extras oh we couldn't
have possibly known about this that's
okay
but just make sure you're in good
communication and make sure that before
you instruct a builder and pay them
you have a clear agreement a written
agreement
of what's expected between you and the
builder i hope you found this video
helpful if you did
hit like and i look forward to sharing
more successful projects with you
real soon thanks
you